father de rire dénicheur de talent
acquis encore démontré ce mardi soir à
la ferme du mousseau à elancourt
l'étendue de son savoir faire son choix
s'est porté sur quatre jeunes humoristes
en devenir pour un spectacle découverte
d'univers très variés
on est dans la configuration du plateau
ça qu'on va avoir la chance ce soir
d'avoir effectivement quatre univers
différents qui vont venir défend les uns
après les autres leurs leur univers pour
le public c'est l'occasion de d'avoir ce
panel la d'humoristes complètement
différent après je faire l'instruction
des uns et des autres mais c'est juste
mon maître de cérémonie de ce spectacle
c'est surtout une rencontre avec le
public c'est une rencontre pour eux
c'est un public différent n'est pas
paris on est dans un public qui va venir
qu'ils découvrent peut-être pour la
première fois ce que cette le stand up
qui est une particularité quand même
dans memory stick et puis en plus il y
avait l'idée sur sur est en cours et sur
saint-quentin de montrer un peu ce
travail que de suivi artistique nous
menons aussi avec des kits quoi
andy bown i'm in july galibert ou encore
ken khojandi connu pour sa mini série
bref se sont succédé sur scène pour une
soirée passée dans le rire et la bonne
humeur doublé chuchoter
ce qui est intéressant c'est est ce que
les gens vont être assez curieux pour
venir voir l'intégralité du spectacle
là ils vont avoir juste un aperçu avec
un seul personnage là pendant 20 minutes
est-ce que ça va leur donner envie à ses
envies pour pouvoir voir l'ensemble je
reprend là où j'en étais avant c'est à
dire je reprends pas là par la petite
porte
l'humour et je crée mon humour s'agit
d'être marrant et soi même ça le vrai
combat
et puis j'ai rencontré à l'époque je
leur dirai juste avant bresse en fait
c'était il n'avait il avait embauché
dans la troupe du jamel comedy club il
avait la gestion la troupe super moment
et avec lui j'ai compris ddd vraiment
des super truc de pas forcément maîtres
d'enjeux dans sa prestation juste mettre
du plaisir et de la recherche d'âcre et
de la création sur avec le public et ça
c'est assez assez cool et puis c'est un
mec super détendu sur les invités et m'a
dit ouais je retrouve avec plaisir
papy ça se refuse pas comme leurs aînés
jamel debbouze ou sophie aram peut aussi
accompagner par tapie se rend-il
conquérir le public
julie galibert sera le 20 avril au
perray-en-yvelines pour l'intégralité de
son spectacle c'est arrivé près de chez
elle
quant à ken khojandi en dehors des
planches il travaille aussi à
l'adaptation de brefs au cinéma